the basic so my thinking don't always
change his about things but in terms of
the basic idea that book was called the
company a short history of a
revolutionary idea and the basic idea
behind it was that actually the this
boring institution the company the
joint-stock company actually was a
revolutionary technology it took an idea
about a way to run businesses a way to
be able to bring in outside capital and
above all the idea of limited liability
and that actually completely transformed
the world if you if he was an example
getting back to what we originally said
you know when the joint stock company
first appeared back in I think
Elizabethan England and then helped in
many ways colonize America at that
precise time you would argue that the
Islamic world had much much more
advanced commercial structures than the
European Bank that European world did
what happened in fact is that the Islam
got left behind and one big reason for
that was they were unable to come up
with a structure partly to do with
actually reasons to do with religion and
inheritance and stuff like that which
could actually deal with joint stock
companies that make it that made a big
difference I think the company is still
an amazing organization watch what comes
out of the current crisis about it it's
harder and we could argue that to some
extent when you looked at banks the
concept of limited liability hasn't gone
remedies it has been very limited
liability for the people at the top of
them that the full way in which
capitalism was supposed to work whereby
people who who did very well will then
supposed to lose a huge amount when they
went it's true people the top of banks
have have lost quite a lot of money but
there's still a general feeling out
there that that people have got a lot
for nothing and what what treats me on
that is a particular thing to do with
the company we know we argue is a
revolutionary organization but it's
always relied on some degree of a
franchise from society
whenever companies whenever corporate
capitalism is seen to go too far in some
direction or another there's usually not
always for the better but there's always
been some degree of backlash there's
always been some degree of we want this
back it's worth remembering a team a
companies exist because of the state
they
exist because the state decides to give
uniquely to a company the concept of of
limited liability if you gave a store I
gave us then that's you know that's
asked personally but a company has that
ability just to keep all its debts
within itself and the people behind it
not to be not to be hit for the for the
full bill and that that is a you know
that that is a privilege given by the
state and although in general I'm much
more frightened about there being far
too much regulation after the particular
this particular episode we're still
getting through you know there's there's
a reason at least conceptually to
imagine why people might want to
re-examine that that relationship